when it comes to picking a relational
database you might find yourself
comparing two options a postgresql and
MySQL and this isn't an easy decision as
there are many similarities between them
but give me a couple of minutes
and I think I can guide you in the right
direction
oh oh and I I have a joke to share about
postgresql and MySQL written by
artificial intelligence you won't want
to miss it so before we explore how they
are different let's briefly ask how
postgres SQL also known as postgres and
MySQL are similar because they do share
a number of similarities
for example both are relational database
Management Systems relational database
management
systems rdbms which means they organize
data into tables both rely on SQL
or structured query language which is
the standard language for interaction
with Management systems with SQL
analysts don't need to know where a
given table is like for example an order
table we don't need to know where it
resides on disk or how to perform the
lookup to find a specific order in that
table or how to connect that order table
to another table like a customer table
together because the database compiles
the query and figures out all of the
correct data points
and both also support jaison so that's
the JavaScript object notation to store
and transport data
but postgres SQL and MySQL offer
fundamentally different value
propositions
so postgres is one of the most compliant
stable and mature relational databases
available today and it's very good with
complex queries postgres is object
relational and it appeals to Enterprise
database administrators responsible for
managing online transaction processing
that it's O ltp and oltp firmly goes
under the progress SQL column
and it provides those protocols for
business activities like e-commerce like
customer relationship management and
like Financial ledgers
it's also ideal for managing the
analytics of a data received created and
generated now why is that well some of
the benefits of postgres are first of
all related to Performance
and to scalability
so postgres has a number of performance
and scalability features including
extensive data analysis across multiple
data types
there's also m v c c that's
multi-version concurrency control and
that enables the simultaneous occurrence
of write operations and reads and
there's also business continuity
support with postgres and that's
provided with high availability of
services through asynchronous or
synchronous replication methods across
servers
if you need to process complex queries
with multiple data type support and if
you're looking for a database with great
concurrency control postgres should be
your go-to option now my sequel on the
other hand is an open source relational
database management system that's been
around for a long time it's very well
established and it's known for being
easy to use and being very fast making a
popular choice for web applications in
particular
MySQL is typically used for smaller
scale web apps that don't need the same
level of performance and complexity as
Enterprise applications although it is
used sometimes there as well
and some of the other benefits of MySQL
are just the ease of use
it's a very easy to use database system
and it's also been very very optimized
fast to get it up and running and get
started and that really goes to my next
point which is speed so for the support
for high speed partial indexes that's
full text indexes and there's unique
memory caches that can result in
Superior database performance and there
is also support for scalability
with my SQL with support for unlimited
storage growth and a small footprint if
you're looking for a fast easy to use
database for small to medium-sized web
applications MySQL is a great option
oh yeah and and I don't want to forget
my AI generated joke created by a
generative pre-trained Transformer it
basically goes something like this
there's a mySQL database administrator
and they were showing a postgres data
admin around his office so the my SQL
admin showed her the the server room
it's stacked full of servers and the
postgres SQL admin was impressed then
the MySQL admin showed her the room
where the backups were stored racks and
racks of storage very impressive the
postgres admin said and then finally the
MySQL administrator took her to the
rumor the developers worked the postgres
administrator was shocked to see that
there was only one developer working
there why do you only have one developer
she asked because the MySQL
administrator replied with my sequel we
don't need any more
maybe it's just me but I actually do see
the humor in that because my sequel is
powerful yet easy to use it doesn't need
a lot of development resources so look
broadly speaking here if you need a
database for an Enterprise application
that can handle complex queries and
multiple data types you might want to go
with postgres if you need a fast easy to
use database for small to medium-sized
web applications you might choose to go
with mySQL and if you want to write
database jokes well
well that's a problem for another day